là on est entré dans la stratégie la
salle de classe et de la stratégie il ya
deux choses que c'est l'autre à la faute
aussi pas te lâcher tout la stratégie et
la marche du bateau marche du bateau
allait toujours moins ils n'ont pas nous
on al'avantage d'avoir joué au racing
c'est fabuleux
ils n'ont pas à bord comme certaines
d'envoi le moderne et non pas à bord de
ce pilot m pour savoir la justesse
l'année avec notre île de sainte anne et
apprendront il fait son petit bourg
tranquille et tu essaies petit mort avec
sa pagaie bon il en serait le faire ce
qu'il peut peut-être que la voile est un
peu borné vous ce petit jour là ils sont
quatrièmes ils sont quatre voix la liste
cette année c'est quand même une belle
performance et une belle prestation de
belle performance que nous fait sept
viols cette année express de cette anne
haye devant donc avec marquez mayol
florian qui on rappelle est toujours à
la recherche de partenaires et de
sponsors
donc vous voyez avec les cette belle vue
d'ensemble le prêcheur qui va bientôt se
présenter à nous pour l'arrivée donc de
cette première étape de ce 34e tour de
martinique des yoles rondes l'ambiance
commence déjà à monter sur un la plage
oui vous voyez déjà donc les fans sont
larry supporter également son âge on va
sentir les casquettes on va sortir les
drapeaux les fanions les maillots aussi
parce que tout ce que ça fait partie du
poids économique
d'ailleurs on aura le temps d'en
reparler gens parce qu'on a toute la
semaine on sait que le taureau logipays
pèse d'après les dires les cils team
millions d'euros voilà mais il ya
beaucoup de choses alors déjà dix
millions dix millions connus répertoriés
et puis peut-être comme antidote
millions dans la nature alors là on va
voir on va voir une arrivée ordinaire on
voit les deux bouts et qui se sont à
à gauche de l'écran à ma gauche à la
droite de l'écran pour vous et puis bon
ce serait se serait fait listerine mais
qui arriveraient sous embargo ramillon
sa manoeuvre extrêmement payante et
l'arrivée il pas directement mais ce que
ce qu'il a fait c'est ce que je vous
disais il a couvert un moment ils
étaient tentés de ville et pour revenir
vers la ligne mais il a attendu en fait
que son mari petit navire lance le
virement reviennent vers le trio
priorité mais ça ne s'est pas passé
comme ça et lui même temps il est très
bon vin il va devoir et les scribes aura
mieux il est devant là ils assurent yens
bonne distance ils peuvent s'y soit et
coupe la ligne directement soit ils ont
l'option de faire un virement de bord
mais c'est une très très très belle
manoeuvre venir d'où il était relancé sa
yole éclat alger a coupé la ligne comme
ça si tout à fait remonter voilà c'est
réglé pour un champion qui remporte la
première étape de ce tour de martinique
des yoles rondes les supporteurs sont
bien sûr aux anges danser l'instant
kyriba bon on va la retrouver kelly avec
fait l'expérience pour venir un peu
parce que on aimerait savoir comment il
a vécu cette première étape entre
difficultés entre reprises j'ai envie de
dire deux ans mais de la course et tous
à voir un peu comment faire espérer le
patron a géré cette première étape
parti seul en tête du côté de chelsea
hier non voilà on connaît le premier
vainqueur pour moi donc de ce 34e tour
de martinique c'est la yole ufr
champions qui s'impose donc aux
prêcheurs tout à l'heure nationale le
système g au racing on va vous donner
les écarts
éventuellement également au niveau de
cette arrivée du côté du prêcheur la
deuxième violent qui va donc arriver
c'est aussi beau une voiture vraiment
c'est ce qui serait peut-être un peu
déçu les frères au maire guy albert y
aller parce qu'effectivement il pensait
obtenir cette victoire d'étape mais
effectivement 1 face à lui il ya quand
même un vieux loup il ya quand même
quelqu'un qui a envie de remporter ce
tour il faut gagner le tour il faut
aussi marquer un peu trop peut être et
gagner déjà ils établissent effet
l'expérience fr jean floc'h qui les a
coiffé donc cela fait tant qu et voilà
que laguiole 10ème un petit la version
la règle est donc arrivé en deuxième
position n'aura les écarts dans pas
longtemps de cela 2 3 minutes à voyager
sur un petit banc comme ça on assure un
bon trois minutes c'est beaucoup c'est
beaucoup c'est beaucoup ça veut dire que
laguiole va vite c'est qu'elle a bien
négocié à peut-être que du côté de
rohmer des frais au maire et un petit
peu d'abattement de voir qu'on s'est
fait rattraper qu'on n'a pas les choses
en même en ce sens les guérir mais
guerrier il continue à une belle
deuxième place aux pêcheurs c'était pas
évident la congé surtout que c'était mal
parti pour les pâtes il ya eu beaucoup
de rebondissements beaucoup de stratégie
je voudrais m'adresser des stratèges qui
jouaient les patrons et les connaît mais
les stratèges ont joué là alors sur la
rai qui arrive en deuxième position et
le temps il devrait être à peu près de
dix minutes 57 secondes
on ne signale aucune 50 sec de retard
pour le moment pour se marrer petit
l'india qui fait 2e au prêcheur la
troisième yole
c'est appétit d'appaloosa les appétits
d'appaloosa donc lancé on aura les
écarts dans pas longtemps et puis le
rouzic et du babot dans un petit moment
avec avec quelqu'un du fr chanteur bon
si l afrique cite enfin sinon parole
aussi allé de patron
y'a aucun problème donc pour eux
interrogé donc un équipage du fr
champions qui remporte cette première
étape ici du côté du prêcheur devant son
arrêt que petit navire avec un retard de
1 sec conséquent si t'arrives sap et il
appelle aussi les appétits bon là il est
entre la yole est en train de virer le
board virer de bord il va essayer de se
rapprocher de la ligne le vent est un
peu tombée on est à 4,5 vend pas
beaucoup de points on fait très
attention
ce virement de bord a été accompli pas
encore né le vent le vent n'est pas
donnant le vent refuse de voir aussi ce
mouvement refuse elle va vers la terre
bon mais où elle est à l'intérêt reste
et où elle est à se rapprocher de la
terre et faire un autre vie on m'a
d'abord pour arriver à koupéla bruit
quel point c'est coupé sur ce bon mais
là elle et bâbord amure laguiole et
bâbord amure elle valait à la terre on
reprend n'est pas son corps bien reparti
au bord la voile est un repas et on va
tenter de couper cette ligne en
troisième position une belle troisième
place aussi posture très belle troisième
place pour les déficits à tomasz loïc et
laurent qui
devrait punir un troisième de cette
étape ou et bravo phoenix et à ses
équipiers est donc belle victoire pour
cet équipage du fr chance l'eau qui a
galéré l'année dernière et qui veut
remettre un peu les pendules à l'heure
et montre effectivement que le patron
reste fait l'expérience champion de
martinique on rappelle le chat pratique
2018 une affaire champions appétit
l'appaloosa qui se bat toujours contre
le vent qui se bat contre le court mais
qui va essayer de finir quand même sur
la troisième marche du podium du côté du
prêt sur le pré show qui va quand même
recevoir deux fois la flottille c'est
assez exceptionnel quand même cette
année puisque la le pêcheur qui va
accueillir
l'arrivée de cette première étape est de
mais on a encore on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler gens mais ce sera précieux
prêcheur le maire de mont soleil nadeau
que nous saluons des jours bien sûr de
nous accueillir dans sa commune a fait
vraiment ce qu'il faut et c'est bien
d'avoir trois étapes de mettre en valeur
la commune du prêcheur même si ce n'est
pas une commune de violeur mais c'est
une commune de même commune de marins on
va le voir de mer va voir les
recomptages qu'il faut aller virer lille
et la pnl aujourd'hui belle
manifestation belle arrivée un beau
temps belle fête pour ceux qui sont
atteints alors lier l'appaloosa zapetti
l'appaloosa va finalement coupé la ligne
d'arrivée sur ce bord tribord m'enfin
c'est un peu galère à la fin quand on
est comme ça on a juste une envie c'est
de couper la ligne d'arrivée parce que
surtout si on a assuré sa troisième
place ce qui je crois est le cas enfin
dans cette zone assez compliqué quand
même gérer pour pour les embarcations
tantôt les avants elles n'avancent pas
kelly babeau kelly sur la plage avec
félix mérine nous sommes dans l'axé l'ex
merino qui rend hommage à camille
famille d'abord franchement il m'a
beaucoup amusé en fait merci à la vx
félix étape riche en rebondissements
ben oui bien sûr c'est vrai on avait la
tête de la course depuis aux pêcheurs à
chercher la précédente et tours de la
terre on a perdu
ils ont fait des bonds judicieux c'est
très bien qu'après comme le bas aussi on
a pu voir une autre voix les noms on a
repris la tête j'ai dit c'est dommage
qu'on dit albert
parce que je vois une apa il n'a pas
beaucoup de dix pages ils étaient
allaités est bon mais c'est la condition
pour vous justement de bonne augure vous
avez parler d'ambition de bonne augure
pour les prochaines étapes
eh bien oui bien sûr parce savez ça fait
ça fait trois ans qu'on n'a pas gagné
quand même ça fait quand même beaucoup
pour une équipe comme nous ça fait ça
fait long et aujourd'hui enfin se
préparer cette année bon j'espère que ça
va continuer s'est passé pas toujours
facile hein qui vont malgré tout le
temps bon mais c'est le jeu et j'aime ça